so hello everyone thank you for joining
today's session uh we'll be starting
with the session in few more minutes
we are waiting for rest of the
participants to join
all right I can see that few
participants have joined so hello Dinesh
hello James hello Olu vasigan hello Dr
Ramesh
um we'll be starting with the session in
four minutes
and meanwhile we are waiting it would be
great
um if you could introduce yourself in
the chat box
about your educational background and
research interests
all right so uh Dinesh says um his
background is in chemistry and his
research interest is in drug discovery
all right uh can you also let us know if
you're joining with us for the first
time or have you previously attended our
chem informatics webinar
[Music]
all right it's your first time so you're
yet to enroll for the program right
and uh what about the rest of the
participants uh we'll be starting in few
more minutes
so uh it would be great if the
participants can introduce yourself in
the chat box just like the niche so that
uh
you can get know if you're joining for
the first time or have you enrolled for
the program
all right Neda is joining for the very
first time
and uh Dr Sarah is from microbiology and
molecular genetics background
[Music]
I'm curious to know about the rest of
you as well
sanubar says he's enrolled for the
program perfect
and Ahmed is from a bioinformatics and
computational biology background
all right and James ogidi is a
pharmacist and has research interest and
discovery of drugs for neurodegenerative
disease therapy and only Western is from
a pharmacy background as well and has
interest in discovering anti-tumor
regions and have involved with the
program perfect mahanas Is Yet To End
work for the program and would like to
know uh about the live sessions of this
program
and sufian is also coming here first
time and this from molecular biology
background
and James has already enrolled for the
program perfectly we have a mix of
participants who are enrolled and for
yet to enroll so meanwhile the
participants are introducing themselves
in the chat box I'll start with the
today's session so hello everyone a very
warm greeting to one and all my name is
srigori Krishna Kumar and I would like
to welcome you all for the very first
session of the game informatics for
biomedical drug Discovery program this
program is designed for beginners and
students who are eager to learn about
the fascinating field of computational
structure biology and chem informatics
and in today's session we are joined by
our program Mentor Dr puneet kakar Who
will cover several topics on molecular
structure of biological macromolecules
protein structures recent advancements
in drug Discovery protein protein
interactions biomolecular
crystallization among several other
topics
so before we begin with today's session
let me also take a brief moment to
introduce you to the team behind the
program we are us-based buy-informatics
company who is working with multiple
academic and Commercial collaborators to
develop easy to use analytical tools and
our mission is to make bioinformatics
more accessible
and as a part of the program students
will have access to the omic storage
training that has been completed by over
24 000 participants from 187 countries
in over 300 workshops and this training
has been completed by participants in
six different specialization tracks that
includes oncology infectious diseases
Precision medicine Neuroscience data
science for biomedical data
and students will also have access to
the almost logic resources which takes a
combination of training modules data
analysis tools curated project data sets
and interactive sessions with mentors to
give the students a clear path of the
Bloom's taxonomy pyramid
and this also comes with an access to
the owning strategic courses which
include courses on bioinformatics
Precision medicine multi-omics that
consist of genomics transatomics
metagenomics and epigenomics data
science that includes bioinformatics
using R in python as well as chemical
matter and example projects of different
fields which you could learn from and
replicate for your research
end users will also be given directions
to act as Duty buy and pro platform for
biased magic processing and Analysis of
data the platform includes demo pipeline
as well as data management and Analysis
Cloud infrastructure to run the biomatic
pipeline and different stages of
analysis are performed on different
sections on the small diamics platform
so now to view the various courses and
example projects student projects you
need to first sign up on the almost
logical portal I can see that several of
the participants are joining us for the
first time so let me walk you through a
brief demo on how you can sign up
so I'm sharing the link to the learn
portal in the chat box
so uh please visit the link and I'll
walk you through how you can sign up so
when you visit the link you will be able
to see an option that says create an
account when you click on that
uh you will be able to either login uh
sign up using uh by adding your name
email ID and password or you can sign up
using any of your social media apps this
could be Google Facebook account Apple
account GitHub account or even Twitter
and for those participants who have
already enrolled for the program and who
already have an account on the portal
you can simply click on the login now
option that you see here and click on
sign so
um I'd like to request the participants
to quickly let me know in the chat box
if you have signed up or not
if you have signed up please put a done
and if you
are yet to sign up once you have signed
up please put a yes so that I know I can
proceed further and if you are facing
any kind of technical issues you can
share them as well in the chat box and
I'll be happy to
answer has signed up and what about the
rest of you
all right so I can see that participants
are signing up so I'll proceed along so
that if if the participants have any
queries you can let me know in the chat
as well so since I already have an
account on the portal I'm going to click
on sign in
and once you sign in you will be able to
see the various courses and exam
projects that are there
so you can simply enter the keyword that
you are looking that you are interested
in the search bar that says looking for
a specific course so for instance can
informatics and that will show you the
courses um that is associated with Canon
format and now uh the most important
part for the participants who have
enrolled for the program as well as the
participants who are yet to enroll you
need to update your account on the
portal for that you can click on the tab
that says welcome back with your email
ID
and once you click here you will be able
to see your profile settings when you
come here you'll be able to see an icon
that says profile click on that and that
will enable you to edit all the account
settings and some of the important
features that you need to update on your
account is first is that you need to
enter your name and make sure that it is
in proper capitalization and you need to
upload a profile image for yourself at
last you have to add a bio about uh your
that will consist of your education
background and research entrance and
finally you can link your social media
handles as well
and now you'll also see various tabs in
your profile section that is activity
wherein the community manager and the
program Mentor will be tracking your
learning progress under the courses tab
you will be able to see the various
courses that you're currently completing
and under the programs tab you'll be
able to see the program progress that
you are making once you enroll for any
of the omnithologic programs and finally
after the completion of your coursework
and Associated assignments the
certificates will appear under the
certificates so that was all about
signing up and navigating through the
portal so
um if the participants have no further
queries I'll pass on the stage to the
program Mentor who's starting with
today's session that along the way if
the participants have any queries please
feel free to share it in the chat and
we'll be happy to answer foreign
thank you very much
I hope you are able to see I have I hope
you are able to hear me loud and clear
yes
very good let me share my screen
okay screen the whole
okay let me see it
yes
uh
are you able to see my screen
yes sir uh the slideshow is showing up
yes and how it is
very good
talking to the top
do this one more
this is an option just turn on the laser
point okay yeah okay all right so thank
you very much for joining today's
session it is more on the structure
biology side
we will cover some of the basic stuff in
uh
the biomechromolecule site first of all
so that when we go a little complex
in the upcoming session you are well
acquainted with what we are talking why
are we talking about those things and
these are very very basic maybe you are
already aware of it but you will need to
see a little better this different this
perspective of
how we are seeing the cell how are we
seeing the porous cell membrane how are
we seeing the structure of a DNA or a
protein and likewise
let me begin with the presentation
outline we'll talk about little bit on
the cell the unit of life I know most of
you are very much familiar but there
will be a certain aspect of it that you
will connect at the fifth point of this
slide
then we'll talk about the central dogma
which is something very briefly we'll
discuss about
the flow of information why are we
talking about it you'll understand
bio macromolecules DNA and protein some
bit of their structure so that in case
you and you need a quick recap of what
um and how they are connected there
should be covered here then we go to the
exercise on DNA protein sequence and
structures
and then we'll talk about protein
protein interaction and
together how you can connect the cell
and how the drug Discovery campaigns
start and you can visualize those things
um in the in the whole process
so I will not take much time just will
move forward and I hope you will enjoy
some session the whole session will be
pretty much covered in several Hands-On
activities so be with me
all right first thing first we are
talking about the cell we are talking
about the basic unit of structural uh
structure of life right we are saying
the animal cell is something which is
very fundamental whenever we are talking
about the drug Discovery we have to
understand when we are talking about a
medicine that we take it where oral or
the intravenous route where it goes how
it works where it interacts what are the
key parameters that are responsive for
it
that is something which is very very far
from here
we have to cover so many milestone in
between but the overall fundamental is
we should know what are the constituents
of the cell what happens within the cell
environment what happens outside the
cell environment
what making the difference between
internal and external region of the cell
how the cell communicates internally and
externally
and many more things
important thing that we need to
understand that our body is made up of
cells billions of cells actually
and the cell we are saying which is
represented here that you have studied
in your
school education it's not many things
um cells are of different types
cells are primitive cells are advanced
animal or plant cells eukaryotic cells
primitive like prokaryotic cells
uh there is basic difference uh in
animal and plant cells some organelles
subcellular parts are different
chloroplasts for example
present in plant cells but not in human
uh very well defined nucleus present in
eukaryotic cell but not in prokaryotic
cells many other components which are
responsible for certain specific type of
function
all things are very very important in
general the cell can have three main
critical Parts one is the cell membrane
which covers the cell protect us from
the outside environment so that nothing
like everything is going inside and
anything from the inside is going
outside it's very much regulated
second is the
cytoplasm side which where all the cell
organelles are basically
swimming around
and the third part is the well-defined
nucleus which has its own nuclear
membrane and inside that as a chromatin
or chromosome which is present
which regulates the flow of information
so the membrane of the cell is seems
very smooth but it is not actually
it has
pores the fluid mosaic model if you have
studied in the past you should revise
that one where the it is made up of
lipids and proteins proteins are
floating around and membrane is like has
a
capacity to include a proteins which are
having the flanking region outside the
cell environment outside so everything
is
outside the cell outside the cell
membrane is the extracellular
environment anything which is inside
this intracellular environment so it is
important to differentiate intracellular
and extracellular environment and you
will see in the last slide why are we
saying this
now body is made up of multiple organs
foreign system organ systems if you go
little bit down you take out one organ
which is made up of tissues multiple
types of tissues any tissue is made up
of cells in fat so cell is something
which is basic structure that defines uh
the life and it is important that
constituents should be very much a
structure you should know about that
in general some structures some cellular
come
parts of the cells are like mitochondria
kind of Powerhouse you have rough
endoplasmic reticulum which has the
endoplasmic reticulum and encoded with
the you know this the
ER endoplasm reticulum is embedded with
kind of ribosomes for protein synthesis
you have some vacuoles you have called G
vesicles Golgi apparatus which defines
the fate of the products protein
products where they should go they
should be targeted whether they are
going to the cell membrane they are
going excessively space they are going
to any other place
and the main um
in in cytoplasm and nucleus uh and the
chromatin and the DNA which is present
trans
cribe Translate
into uh protein products which are
responsible for basically messaging and
providing necessary function with the
cell
so in in short cell has many things
there is a division of labor kind of
thing where organelles has their own
defined functions very critical
and there are a lot many things needs to
be understood in in in cells so that the
uh the the concept of drug Discovery
delivery should be little bit
um understand clearly or should be
understand clearly
now
when we are saying we are taking any
medicine it goes into the stomach and
intestine then blood then it has to go
across the whole body
then with the help of blood it has to
reach to individual cells where the
blood supplies are also there right
because they are also receiving
nutrients food from the blood
now when you wake you are taking any
medicine the medicine also delivered to
a place where the cells are ready to
take up the medicine
so medicine has to be has to reach to a
place now sometimes medicine has some
specific Target will talk about those
targets if you don't know what is the
meaning of Target don't worry about it
but understand that there are some micro
molecules
biomechromolecules which are important
for certain
um
certain function so that if their
function is modified the disease can be
cured now the drug drug molecule has to
reach to the place where the target is
present now if the target is on the cell
membrane it has to bind to the Target
which is on the cell membrane and should
trigger the function necessary function
but what if the target is something
inside the cytoplasm it means that your
drug molecule has to penetrate go inside
the
um
cell environment and reach to the Target
and a sufficient quantity or wherever
the the requirement number of molecules
are required basis the expression of the
particular Target
sometimes targets are located on the
nuclear membrane or the dnas can be also
a Target in such cases
um drug has to cross all the barriers
right from the oral
um
oral um cavity or intestine liver kidney
blood and then reach to the cell
membranes
um across the cell membranes all travel
through till the receptor placed in the
nuclear membrane and then bind it now
you you have some idea what we are
talking about we are talking about
something at a level of cellular
structure we are saying that even if
your aim is to make a molecule which can
act as a drug it means that you are
looking for something where the drug
should go and bind where these targets
are present these targets are nothing
but where they are present in nowhere
but on the on the cells or the cell
surface
something I I believe you you are with
me let me go to the next level
we are talking about the cell we are
saying the cell is made up of multiple
things
and we also said that there are many
macromolecules which Acts on the product
made by the cell
okay all right products made by cell
what are those products these products
are proteins
macromolecules mostly the proteins are
the targets and very important topic of
today's discussion as well how the
proteins are made the proteins are made
basis what is the
what is the flow we call this flow of
genetic information which passes from
DNA to RNA and on the protein if you see
the left hand side image we say that DNA
which is present where in the nucleus it
transcribe into the RNA RNA goes and
produces the protein in the cytoplasm
now this protein is produced in
cytoplasm but it has to be targeted also
right it has to be targeted on the cell
membrane it has to be a nuclear membrane
on the cytoplasm so all the fake or
maybe extracellular environment of the
cell so that specific sub organelles
um or analysis of the cell functions
that way but important here is the
proteins is produced from the very
regulated controlled fashion very
foolproof method
um after a lot of proof reading
a correct accurate protein has to be
made for a certain specific functions
okay all right but is it that simple no
actually each and everything is very
very complex here just little bit of
sophistication is shown on the right
hand side image where you see the DNA
portion which is making the RNA which is
giving the information that what has to
be transcribed which protein has to be
produced has to uncoil and and should
open the Strand so that the RNA can be
made for that specific reason but DNA is
highly coiled super coil in forms of the
chromosome when you
um when you ex when you when you do the
um
the
um I would say when you loosen the
chromosome you get the chromatin fiber
chromating fiber is still coiled on the
condensed chromatin which are basically
um coiled over the histone proteins and
then if you um uncoil them you get the
double helical structure of the DNA some
part of the DNA should open up create
the MRNA
coiled it again and form this whole
function that the whole structure now
this part for example is going to
produce the MRNA which is created here
and then RNA is used to produce the
protein so in short
all the information of what has to be
produced is encoded in the form of a
chromosome in the form of a DNA or Gene
and that is in turn
present in chromosome
cell is busy in producing so many
protein products inside the cell all the
time that's why many
is a very busy machine you can say it's
a very busy machine
now what is important is
in the whole process of manufacturing
the proteins
there are some mistakes also happens
there are many mutations we call it as
the modification of the amino acid or
modification in the DNA happens because
of many
um many effect on the on the environment
present in the environment or we are
exposed to uh during our development
type
this causes the modifications and these
modification leads to a different
protein now if the protein is changed
the function is also going to be
impacted because it's a highly regulated
process
and the structure is also very much
concerned so that it can it can do a
good job for its basis is structure
you will see those things in in the
coming slides but point is that when
when there are certain changes happens
in the product the changes leads to
certain diseases many times it change it
leads to a certain disease because the
protein is not functional protein which
is produced is not good quality it is
not doing its job correctly or it is
extra produced it shouldn't be produced
but it has somehow produced or it has
um an added
functionality which is not required in
the body for example
in such cases we we see there is a
disease because there is a disease there
is a problem problem is has to be you
know solved so we have a drug Discovery
in mind that's why people use external
molecules uh different therapeutic
strategies to
somehow
Rectify or correct the function or
somehow modify the process so that
natural process should be
um should be uh should should be
preserved into the system and this is
and the the C should be cured or we can
stop the preparation of the disease but
in all the cases are not possible there
are so many diseases
all right we said that the process of
from DNA to RNA RNA to protein is there
but you can ask me why how the DNA looks
like now you have also studied that part
so everything is very redundant maybe
for you but now the story is that you
need to see those things in from the
structural point of view and that's the
topic for today's discussion when we say
the structure point of view is that you
should know how they are actually in
reality uh look like and when we say
that okay DNA is made up of base pairs
which are nothing but four atgc adenine
timing cytosine and guanine and G pairs
with C A plus 50 and double upon two
hydrogen bonds 300 ones in like that you
see in the left hand side image you have
editing thymine you have iron bonds here
and you have um
burning you have cytosine and you have
heightened bonds here but exactly how
they look like we have a protein data
bank and drive will tell you how to
search it because it's a very well known
bio macromolecular structure database
and it's a very key initial point for
you to go for the rational drug design
but before that understand that DNA is a
double helical structure it has four
bases and in thymine cytosine this is
how they interact and
they are the pairing is important if the
pairing is disrupted it may not
either uncoil may not be break broken in
by the protein enzyme if it is uh broken
then it cannot be
um
uh joined again and it may cause
problems and because such cases are
known the drug Discovery also happen
that way that we design molecule that
binds to the DNA
on the right hand side you have a
protein now protein has multiple level
of structures we call it as primary
structure secondly tertiary and
quaternary but it's very fundamentals
very important we should understand what
do they actually mean by doing some
Hands-On exercise
we are saying the primary structure of
the protein is nothing but the sequence
of the protein and we will talk so many
times about the protein sequence and
structure in the upcoming sessions as
well
the amino acid names are encoded by
three letter code here aspergine
glycines
[Music]
glutamate something like that for all
the other amino acid and
in the sequence
it is written as a single letter quote
for the amylase
now
single letter codes are standard
defined already if you go to the Google
just search for the amino acid symbol
you will get it and they are pretty
standard when we write in a
in a single format they are called the
protein sequences there are many
specific formats but most wide widely
accepted used format is called faster
format
we'll talk about the faster format any
moment and when I will show it to you
so that's a protein sequence as a
primary structure when we take
additional information other than
protein structure so you have a protein
structure though we call it as primary
structure
of the protein
it is actually not a structure it is
just a protein sequence
there's no structure this the structure
is how the amino acids are connected to
each other that information is given to
you
so that's a primary structure of the
protein the secondary structure has
added information that what part of the
protein sequence is made up of alpha
helices
and what part of the protein sequence is
made up of beta strand
we do not have any information that how
they are how do they look like in the
how they are oriented in a
three-dimensional space it means that
you have protein linear sequence one
part of the protein sequence is a is a
alpha Helix and then strand then Alpha l
x and Strand and so on likewise but you
do not have whether they are alpha Helix
are together two alpha ellises are
together it's not that information is
present in the three dimensional
structure of the protein where the
sequence is
oriented in the space
so you will understand which amino acid
position is more closer to which a minus
it position is not always linear
because here if you see the third minus
it here third or minus head is here in
the protein sequence form in this
structure maybe this is the 50th amine
acid which is nearby because it is in a
coil shape in a in a three-dimensional
tone shape right and the same way
in the same way
when you have multiple sequences
together you form the quaternary
structure of the protein
I think I have said enough it's time to
go and look at these two things one by
one
let me go to the database for protein
and DNA so if you are talking about the
sequences of the DNA and protein I have
this one
so
[Music]
if you have um
okay can I just do this one
I don't know how this will
okay now I go to this um
it's called and say
and say what
in CBI
yo guys
ncba nucleotide okay so ncbi nucleotide
is one of the sequence database of DNA
we can say
um
any protein any any protein name where
the DNA we need to identify or any Gene
name we can say we can say for example
this is a uh
pneumo sapiens based one let me see if
there is any so you can search by
accession number or you can
search by any term
whatever
research products project you have in
mind or giving it to you by your um
professor you can look at those entries
you need to ensure that you select the
nucleotide here because there are many
um many other databases offered by the
ncpi you see the base one
is a beta secretary is one
of homo sapiens which is a human
and you have a lot of information about
this one about this particular team the
important information that all are
important but what I am talking about
the important information at this moment
is the pro it's a DNA is a gene sequence
so here you see
um the interactions here if you see uh
Gene information a lot of information I
am scrolling a little fast
and you see the information yes if you
would status
okay keep uh
uh looking to the
information
um which is mRNA protein accession
this is also linking to so the other
informations are also linked here
what you need to see
is to search for
a
genomic sequence faster range from this
to this and you see if I click on the
faster
you will
get the
sequence of the DNA
so you have atgc in a specific order
what it says is it's a faster sequence
of homo sapiens Peter secret is one
uh reference sequence team chromosome at
at chromosome 11.
now the first line that you need to
understand there are multiple formats of
representing the sequences of protein or
DNA this specific format is called
faster format where the sequence starts
with a greater than sign whenever you
see the sequence starting with greater
than sign first line is comment whatever
you want to write you want to write your
name that's fine any experiment name you
want to write that's fine it has no
impact on the sequence itself
the characters of the sequence are one
uh one letter code for the
adenine timing coordinate cytosine which
is
repeated
which is present in a specific order and
that information actually codes for
that information uh codes for the
actual protein
in each line there should be 60
characters and there is no
termination sign for example no end end
sign for example slash comma asterisk
nothing is there so no Gap in the
sequence all are continuous characters
starting with greater than sign that's
the faster sequence format all right so
we have seen faster sequence for the DNA
which is fine let me go and introduce
you with the another database which is
called uniprot
so uniprot is again another very
important database and I can go to the
same protein that I have shown you in
the
um for in the nucleotide Gene which is
PS1 I can go and search for this one
here this one for human
uh this one base one is human p 56817
and if you remember that
was also there
in a link just let me Google
p56 81 7.
you see that's the same protein which is
I have opened it here search here so
base one is present a human Mouse all
are not same
they may be same but they may be
different many times they are different
slightly different even one or minus a
different is it different it can be able
it can lead to a lot of difference it
depends where the difference actually
present
in the protein so let me open this one
you see lot of information will go cover
a lot of things uh in the upcoming
sessions but for for your information at
this moment lot of information is
provided you go to the
sequence and isoform
and you see there are
there is a sequence of the protein
return
this is a very different format not the
faster because not starting with greater
than sign it has gaps it has numbers
um so it is definitely not a faster let
me open the faster one so see this when
I click on Dot
and I clicked on download it has now the
faster formatted sequence
starts with greater than sine SP is just
subscribe
um ID description about the protein the
first line is complete now from the
second line it has one single letter
code for the amino acids which are
methane Ella named glutamine
etc etc etc okay so this is the protein
sequence so this is a primary
this is a primary structure of the
protein the structure is not there but
the structure in the form of a amino
acid order primary structure of the
protein make sense
I show you another database which gives
you a lot of other informations called
protein data back
now protein data bank has a lot of
structures of the protein in a three
dimensions it means in a three
dimensional space mean either tertiary
structure or quaternary structure and
then the accessory information of the
secondary structure of the protein is
also there so let me open the same
protein of the gene base one
or the p56817 there for a
for a
foreign
so let me open this one
just looking for one W five one one
particular entry in protein Data Bank
which should show me the structure which
is like this and let me go to sequence
information
okay
now if you see the sequence information
here you see a lot of information about
the protein family which family it
belongs to it has the class architecture
topology homology the main information
yeah it is showing on top of that so the
family is eukaryotic as partial protease
it is coming here if you see my cursor
and then look at those things
um on the top you will see these things
are changing so you understand where
exactly these things are showing
all right there are other information
thing that I wanted to show seems like
they have changed little bit things in
the
in the overall representation
let me try it
okay now I don't want this one
and space certainly
see okay so they have changed the layout
here the layout is called secondary
structure of the protein so yellow is
showing the
sheet or strand information
and this pink is showing the Helix right
if you see this region here
it is showing
it is changing based my cursor position
if I am click if I am Mouse hovering on
The yellow section rectangle box or
vertical boxes
it is showing the Strand a sheet and
this pink one are nothing but the Helix
so what it is saying if this is a
sequence which portion of the sequence
is either helix or either helix or the
beta strand or sheet
now you can ask me what happens to the
things which are neither Alpha Helix nor
beta strand or sheet they are basically
the loop region the loop Legion is the
the Connecting Point between the two
um between the two secondary structures
so for example this Helix is connecting
to this Helix by means of a loop okay
so that information is given by the
blank
so primary structure is the sequence
which is given here second structure is
giving you the information of which part
of the protein sequence is this Alpha
helix or beta strain the tertiary
structure of the protein is these three
dimensional structure of the arrangement
of these secondary structure let me show
it to you that also but wait a moment
you need to know how to see those
structures and this is very important
you need to do a lot of
[Music]
um
and so on
for to to just to get the full
confidence or the control of the mouse
and how the mouse button behaves because
there are multiple softwares open
certain structure so I will go to the
summary again for one w51
which is here
and I can go to the download file which
is a pdb format file but I will not do
this for this particular protein
and I have a reason for it I wanted to
show you a protein or the entry which
which has both the things protein as
well as DNA so you know the proteins
which binds to the DNA
uh transcription factors
helicases these kind of proteins binds
to the DNA and people have identified
their structures in a in a
in a complex form in a complex means
they are they are where both the things
are present the DNA and the protein so I
have one entry for you let me go to that
quickly One X nine m
okay let me open that one X9 and phase
One X nine and
so Krishna structure of human DNA like
is bound to 5 denihilated Nick DNA the
DNA is neat it's
okay so what I will do
um and you see there is a DNA there is a
protein I will go to download file and I
will go to and click the pdb format
that's this is what I need but how do I
open this file
I need a visualization that can generate
this kind of I will go to that files in
little detail in a completely different
session all together because there are a
lot many details here which we cannot
cover the focus here is to understand to
let you understand
the basics of structures
and somewhat some bit of control on what
you can see in the structure or DNA and
proteins so that you can understand the
latest story of the program
so I have a program there are so many
softwares
um we'll cover those things but there's
one important software which is freely
available is ICM browser
ICM browser so ICM is from molesoft it's
a private company and they provide a
paid softwares but browser is free of
cost so first studies purpose for
educational purpose we can download it I
have downloaded for this program
um if you see ICM browser Pro is there
let me open that one
you can simply Go download put the email
ID and install it a little heavy it will
take some time but you can download it
so this is how the interface is you have
left hand side control you have some
command line operations menu button
um toolbar options and this gray big
screen is for rendering the structure of
the proteins or the biological macro
models so I will go to the file open
open file open what I want to open is
the structure of the protein 1x9 and I
believe that structure should be there
in the download so download is here one
x9n is here don't worry about the
Scandal we'll talk about this one later
and you see
I am loading the structure can anybody
confirm me you are able to see that
structure of this molecule
yeah so we can see the molecule perfect
but very good so I think you are and
what I am doing is I am left clicking my
mouse left button and holding it and
then
moving the mouse
you see I am clicking my left Mouse
button holding it and moving it
are you able to see protein and DNA
together
right in the chat box
are you able to see protein and DNA in
this
rendering
right
are you able to see base pairing
in this structure
say yes or no
yes
very good are you able to see a DNA is
cut
DNA has a breakage
are you able to see
let me move it little bit more are you
able to see any breakage in the DNA
you need to locate yourself
keep your eyes at a place where you can
see
okay
very nice
beautiful structure
experimentally determined
download it from protein Data Bank
DNA ligase protein
working in a way
to join the two ends of the net DNA
um by making a phosphorus Bond yes
on the left hand side you see there are
some chains
um
so these are three DNA that's why they
are you see DCd
um n for nucleotide and a for amino acid
so the protein is single chain
632 a minus it this is how you should
read it if I uncheck it and you see this
orange is orange if I uncheck it the
protein will go away you see protein is
corn
what you are seeing is the DNA but I see
DNA is just one
no the DNA has three strands now
because a double helical structure two
strands goes in parallel
but one strength in this particular
structure is broken that's why you have
three straight three strands one strand
another Nick this trend and third is the
one continuous strain and that's why you
have three the green one is T chain you
see
the other one is yellow C chain and B
chain is this
that's why the whole structure is formed
in this particular entry but you can ask
me this space pairing is not the base
pairing puneet you told me or showed me
in the presentation
is it something
wrong with this structure no actually
not it's just representation of the
protein and the DNA to make your life
easy to understand
we can change that way
for example let me take out
um let me take
remove this one and say this is
[Music]
um
representation so you have the stick
representation of the base pairs or
bases
here also I can make x x stick so that
you can add now you are saying it's too
crowded I can't understand the base
pairing and so and so whatever can you
make it more clear for me so okay what
we can do is we can remove the ribbon
representation so that it becomes little
clear no no remove the other ribbon as
well okay let's do that word okay now I
see
are you able let me remove the fork are
you able okay let me do this white is
too bright let me do a change in the
color are you able to see it now
little clear
ballistic representation of the bases in
a base pair form
so that
you can understand say double helical
structure what we are talking about the
DNA
what we are talking about the DNA okay
that's good
but
um
one thing is missing the one thing which
is missing is the interaction which is
not shown here
between the base pairs for this I need
to do some Magic The Magic here I need
to add hydrogens and prepare it for this
so I will do the right click on the
first
um
form which where the protein entry is
written One X nine and and say convert
pdb so that can
um do a lot of things don't worry about
it optimizing hydrogens and adding
hydrogen is something which is critical
here and let me do this
so it will it is doing this job
automatically so very beautiful software
um
okay still doing
is it doing only for this these two
visible entries no it is doing for
everything for all the amino acid for
all the DNA Etc
okay too complex
let me remove all these because it has
created a clone after processed thing
so I will remove the protein for the
sake of clarity making the DNA is ectic
and you see the hydrogens as white are
added so each atom has a different color
code oxygen is red carbon is green here
and nitrogens are n uh the blue the blue
one
here also I can do a stick here also I
can do X stick and what else I can do is
to
do remove the ribbon
and here also I can remove the ribbon
here also I can
okay this is fine
let me do one more thing
is to view
[Music]
um
are you able to see the hydrogens hair
hydrant bonds should be here
levels
display okay display display hydrogen
you see this button let me click here
and you see what happens in the
in the main screen right
let me remove it some bit of it so that
you can have even clear picture
see okay
now you see head and Bonds are there
adenine thymine two
um cytosine guanine some are
small some are thick bases the distance
between both of them
all right now are you able to see the
hydrogen hydrogen bonds between the
bases
are you seeing the DNA is connected in a
single strand with their backbone
the phosphate
hmm
you are able to see the pairing between
the uh between the bases all right you
see you are seeing a lot of things
believe me you are seeing a lot of
things but you say okay this is good for
DNA but what about this protein I I am
so much interested about the protein
okay let me see the protein part as well
you see this is the whole protein
I can make it more View
view
f11 for full screen so that you can have
really really wonderful
picture and you see the amino acids are
written like the are displayed like this
some of them are only shown for sake of
clarity if I make everything oil and
stick
it becomes too heavy for you let me do
that
it becomes too heavy for you
you see this one
right
maybe not able to understand okay let me
zoom in little bit more
oh it's still crowded right
okay let me see
this one
if I
Proline serene
you see I selected only three amino
acids
and which are here
as I add more a minus it they will keep
on connecting with each other
right they all are connected
I am doing the central click and then
translating it
you see
they are connected with the backbone
um c o n h Bond c o n h Bond c o n h
Bond then C Alpha c o n h c o n s c
Alpha and this is what you have studied
in India
uh
in your in your college days
textbooks okay
so a minus it's this is a three
dimensional structure and now you see
three dimensional structures important
because these two are minor settings C
they are of different number
let me
um label them
[Music]
okay
um
display
residues
okay you see tyrosine 266
and tyrosine 273
these two amino sets are basically
distant amino acid 66 and 73 there's not
66 and 67 but still they are closer to
each other because of the three
dimensional twist
and and that's why three dimensional
structure understanding is important
which cannot this information cannot be
leveraged just by having a primary
structure of the protein and secondly
structured property I hope I am able to
clarify this to you and it is making
some sense to you
let me go back to the presentation
okay so we said that structure now you
have more clarity on that part which is
good let me go to the another section uh
we said that okay you mentioned about
the protein structure uh in good detail
and protein sequences also seen but in
case you have multiple sequences and you
want to see both of them
all all the sequences in one view the
which program should be used and there's
a lot of analysis actually done on the
protein sequences child view is one of
the great application I would say freely
available
absolutely amazing application
to visualize the sequences as well as
the structures of the protein will go to
that part
in a way so what I'm doing is
we are doing just one exercise here
it's like
we'll go to the uni product
and we'll say
okay you need product tell me all the
protein sequences of aspartic proteins
particles particle proteins is
so I searched for asparty proteases you
see
000 results
can you believe it it's just too much
but we cannot we should not download all
of them and do anything we'll
we'll take out
um some organism we can select for
example in human we can select in human
still there are 114 just to make them
simple or easy or small
we will say
show only with five annotations code
means they are very well curated
identified very well
reported
and I can do what I can do download
I'm saying canonical is nothing but the
representative because each protein can
have several variants and that's a
representative one I'm naming I'm not
saying I need the isoform one
I don't need any other format because I
know faster format very well starts with
greater than sign and it has a command
it has a single letter A minus it from
the second line no Gap no number no sign
of termination 60 correctly each line so
I know what the form first of all form
it is so I will do that I am I do not
want to uncompress this that's why I'm
saying no compression and I am
downloading it so this one I downloaded
okay I go to jail view Jail view I
installed from the Javi website
that I can also show it to you go to
Java view
very very beautiful website very
beautiful tool
you see child view a lot of information
about it and you really really enjoy uh
doing this if your work this is what
involves multiple protein sequences in
sequence to be analyzed understand and
do a lot of analysis certainly this can
be a very very good tool you see protein
Data Bank is written structure you can
do alignment you can generate these kind
of things and you have seen these kind
of things in Publications multiple times
and you see the the clustering is also
done which protein is related to which
protein in a closest form or you know
distantly related so
okay
having said that I downloaded this one I
have this one installed I can remove
this one which is good no sample is
required here I can go to the input
alignment from file though it's not
aligned one but I can go with the
sequences
oh three one why there should be more
let me open file
which one is the latest one
I did a lot of downloading 28 one
52 I believe this one
no this is
how do I divide there's no details let
me see details
which one is downloaded
okay
8 32 832 this one
yes this one should be there yeah you
have all the proteins here
all right all right all right so I have
all the proteins here but they are not
aligned what we can do go to the web
services alignment there are so many
functions
I'm doing it just for
preset quick alignment
it is doing quick alignment for us you
see alignment will be done in short
while you will
have the amino acid aligned they are
just arranged one below the other but
they are not aligned you see the
alignment is there
oh there's very less align proteins
because they are very different
I believe proteins let me go to the
color code and say
percentage oh yes you have leucine here
in this particular column which seems
like leucine is a very important
critical minor set
first party proteases here okay good
what else
let me go here and see is there anything
other oh yes you have other reminder
said also very much concerned but very
less conservation among the proteins
which is fine
it's just fine
okay going little fast
okay yeah good couple of my answers
which are
um which are present here
I don't think there is a big line with
all the minus sets very well
conserved so what I will do I will say
um Blossom score okay
so different way you can play around it
you have proteins if you double click on
this you will open the particular
protein entry page you can also embed
the structure of the protein here
which is in the sequence I'll talk about
little bit more with some functions this
particular tool but for sequences
analysis this is the grid tool okay
which is fine we learned it
it was good let me go again to a
particular
to our presentation gel view we have
done this one ICM Pro quickly one x9n we
have seen it now
we talked about cell intercellular
environment structure extracellular
environment space I have a picture here
which says about the therapeutic
strategies for the covid-19
uh treatment
what you are seeing on the image there
are
three two different strategies one is
immunomodulatory kind of approaches
um inflammatory kind of things and
second is the which has the information
about the
virus viral replication okay now you see
this particular portion which is in the
light pink here
you say host cell and you can identify
what is
can you identify this is a nucleus this
is the endoplasmic reticulum this is a
Golgi body
and this is what it is where the things
are reported these are nothing but the
cytoplasm
now you can connect what people are
talking about there are drugs mentioned
for each of these strategies here it
means that people are talking about
having a medicine which can act on the
portion of the
um
or or the arcade to a place in the
cytoplasm or in the extracellular
environment on the transmap on the on
the cellular membrane
and treaty
disease
treat the patient treat the patient and
cure the disease
this is a virus which has four different
things
Spike protein envelope protein membrane
protein nucleocapsule protein protein
rights protein you understand protein
you understand what we are talking about
as a cell you understand this is cell
environment we are talking we already
talked about medicine has to reach to
the place where it should go and bind to
certain biological macromolecule
these are membranes bone protein where
where
virus acts virus binds to it and then go
for endocytosis it uncoats it releases
RNA then to the replication of RNA make
multiple copies it produces a new forms
of
um
multiple viruses and then it release out
different places you have different
strategies you can block the entry of
the virus
um by means of several these several
drugs you can act
um you can act on the RNA replication
part or translation
um part of the ntrna polymerase is uh as
a etc you can act
um
on the protease inhibitor so that this
virus Factory can be taken into
consideration and there are medicines
for it there are other strategies which
can block the release of this particular
um assembly of the viruses
um by using NP viral release strategy
right on the right hand side you have
other inflammatory
um
cytokines related approaches to treat
the
um treat the patient
point is that
there could be multiple things but the
fundamental is where you molecule is
sitting what is your molecule how your
drug will interact with the molecule
and that is all we will talk about in
the coming sessions I hope
with this one you have certain
understanding of at a macro level what
we are talking about what we are looking
into it how we should look into it
now you have prepared for a deep dive in
the upcoming sessions
we also mentioned about the protein
protein interaction which is a string
database and I can give you a very
simple glimpse of how it looks like when
two proteins interact with each other
you will have you need that information
in hand so that you can block that or
you can you can use this as a machinery
for identification of the trucks I can
go to the string DVD
string database and then you see this is
a protein name I can say this one or the
same protein I can take or to detect the
organism we need only the human one
okay this one maybe it is taking in a
different way so let's say this
so it's the same beta side of APB
cleaving enzyme which is fine I am
interested in homo sapiens
let me continue
and is generating the protein protein
reaction means that a protein called
base in the human cells
wherever it is located it interacts with
so many other proteins
these are the proteins so if I need to
design the drug for the base one I need
to consider the artifact that it also
stop interacting it may stop
it may interfere in making the
interaction with the base one to other
proteins and that can cause the problem
all those things needs to be considered
while taking the consideration of the
drug targeting to into the mind
we'll talk about a little bit more on
the targets and what are the
characteristics of the drug Target
should have
while selecting a particular drug Target
for the treatment for the designing of
the molecules and treatment of the
diseases
having said that
I end the session with this particular
note I believe you will do the Hands-On
exercise at your place
download install jar view you should be
able to search
um sequences using uniprod and
nucleotide databases you will download
them open them analyze them little bit
and
you should be able to download the
structure the proteins or DNA from
protein Data Bank install micro moles of
the ICM browser and do Hands-On exercise
let me know if you have any questions I
see a lot many chat points are there
thank you very much
thank you so much sir for that wonderful
presentation uh and we have one query
from Abu
abasti he's asking is there a database
about pathological Pathways about
disease
yes there are multiple databases for the
pathways cake is one pathway reactor is
another pathway and they are indeed
little complex but fundamental for the
pathway is one after the other
connections these connections are
nothing but the connections of the
proteins and other biological
macromolecules
so I believe you should be able to
explore the pathways if you as you
search for reactor
or cake Pathways or Wiki Pathways you
should be able to search them
effectively
thank you sir and we have saptashi
asking what uh is Java software tool
uh what is that
travel
c-a-v-e-r software tool
um cable software okay I am not
available
[Music]
Kevin and there are other variants of it
I am seeing this into the screen it
seems like
uh cold standoff analysts of tunnels and
channels in biology okay so there are
molecular macromolecules biological
macromolecules which makes the tunnels
or iron channels
this particular software is
as the claim is very
um
very effect very efficient analyzing
those tunnels and channels of protein
structures
um go ahead
explore that software I will also do
that it's a good uh information for me
as well
so
there must be I believe certain options
which helps you to calculate the
internal structure the the volume
available in the channels and
um tunnels so that you can have some
designing opportunities you can design
the drugs accordingly
so that's very good if that is available
free of course why not explode it
thank you so much sir so I guess that
was the uh end of the questions uh so I
can see that a lot of the participants
are yet to enroll for the program so for
such participants
um we would like to share the
registration and program details so for
that uh I'd like to pass on the stage to
shubham who will be explaining more
about a program registration over
tuition
um thank you sugary let me first share
my screen
yes we can see the program page
yeah so hello everyone I am shubham I am
the business development marketing
associate here at Pine biotech so I'll
be briefing you about the registration
part for those who haven't enrolled yet
so as you can see this is our program
page so I'm pasting the link so that you
can also go through this link
after this session
and let this
okay
so as you can see this is a program page
for cam informatics for biomedical drug
Discovery and it has like it has been
commenced from today
so yeah when we will scroll down a bit
uh you will see there's a program
overview in this section uh we have
summarized what all the topics or the
concepts you will be learning from this
program as well as how you can apply
this concepts of the topics for a
research project if you are from a
biotechnology background or a Pharma or
any other uh industry so you can like
apply this knowledge so uh when you will
scroll down more uh you can see that
there is an interactive session calendar
here and some of the dates are
highlighted so like today on 28th Jan we
have a first session for the cam
informatics for and we have learned
about the computational structure
biology and some of the topics you can
see from here which we have covered and
yes and the next session we will be
doing tomorrow that is 29th and the
topics which we'll be covering you can
see on the right side of this page
now coming down a bit more
um you can see that we have three
different uh tenures for this program
one is for 45 days 60 days and 90 days
so the common resources we have for all
these tenures is yeah you will get the
online tutorials
then you will go to like you will have
the access of the omics logic learn
platform where you can go through the
project examples related to this
particular program along with that you
will get the coding session and by
chance if you miss any of the session
then we will provide you with the
session recordings you will get the
online mentor and technical support and
after the completion of this program
definitely you will get a certificate of
completion the extra thing what you will
get in the 60 days is uh you will get
the one-on-one Mentor session and let's
say you have a research proposal related
to this and you want to like work on
that thing then you can draft your
research proposal also as well as you
can uh make it a poster and we have that
Symposium then you can present in a
poster presentation
and for the 90 days apart from all this
you will get a specific I plan on for
the team band for server and one on one
minute session and you can independently
work on your research project and get it
published also in the peer review
journal part so these are the different
tenures and the resources with their
outcomes coming to the pricing part as
we can see on the screen uh this is for
you in USD so for 45 days it is dollar
150 for 60 days it is dollar 300 and for
90 days it is dollar 450. let's see some
of them are from India so what you have
to just do is uh you will see a drop
down option here
so you have to click on that and select
the currency
so you can like for the 45 days in INR
we have uh around 7 500 then for the 60
days it is 9 triple nine and for 90 days
it is 14 triple iron and same similar 14
our African Community just click on the
drop down and you can click on this on
naira for the Nigerian ones and you can
see the pricing here as well
now how we can register or how we can
enroll for this particular program so
let's say I'm interested in 93 days
program and simply just you have to
click on buy now
and after that
[Music]
you will see the checkout page and just
you have to fill your user details and
click on this check box and you can see
laptop payment method either stripe or
PayPal if you are facing any issue in
both this payment then we have
Alternatives also uh via pay then and
Via for index you pay option is also
there so we have options for alternative
negotiations
this is all about the registration part
so if you have any query please feel
free so that I can address those things
hello can you hear me
hello
hello yeah can you hear me um from
Nigeria
yeah yeah hello hi hello Lewis again
yeah
um I just have a brief question
um I enrolled for the um chemical Matrix
um program and I'm finding it um
I I really can't I'm not able to locate
the code on on the portal is it I will
search for the camera informatics and
topic on the search bar then the courses
under those are the courses I'm going to
be
um working on what I'm working with
uh like uh like to be precise uh like uh
like what I have understood is you want
to work on the research part right
related to the canvas Romantics yes of
course yeah of course you can work like
uh we will be having live sessions uh
with Dr puneet and after that if you
come up with the research question or a
research proposal and you want to work
on that thing that is awesome
um what I'm trying to say is I'm like
I've not been able to access the courses
on my portal
uh so I
you you can
just make so that we can find the team
like uh there might be some technical
issue so should worry has shared
the contact details so
um mail us at that particular ID so that
we can show you are facing okay thank
you
thank you
thank you so much and there's any
participants have any further queries
if so please feel free to share it in
the chat
[Music]
all right if participants have no
further queries uh along the way if
you're having any questions or concerns
you can reach out to us at the email ID
and the contact number that I've
provided in the chat so please save it
and we'll get back to you uh for any
questions
and with that thank you everyone for
joining today's session and like
shouldn't say we have our next session
tomorrow so uh we look forward to seeing
you
so with that thank you everyone and have
a great
thank you